uh sorry for the bad title I apologize
but so this is this is joint work with
with mother Joanne a leaping out Botha
work colleagues at sandia national labs
and so you know how Andrew gave sort of
a a big survey of the area and I wanted
to talk about a very specific problem
because I thought it would be a nice
contrast with the previous talk but
let's start first with you know theory
in practice so does anyone recognize
what this is it's yeah it's it's the
Shire right yeah you can you see the
circular door and there's Gandalf so for
me Theory is like the Shire it's this
beautiful place it's green it's nice
it's well-defined I know most of the you
know the in theoretical computer science
I know most of the people there a little
early for me takes about half an hour
it's it's it's a beautiful place to be
but and and practices like Mordor it's
this dark I'm sorry to say this but it's
sort of ugly place I'm not really sure
what the right questions are you make
the wrong move and you fall down a huge
crater or whatever it's it's generally
it's it's very messy so this talk is
basically about an inhabitant another
child goes to war with the triangle
actually so uh so yeah there and back
again but uh but anyway so yeah what's
the what's in a body oh we we love
triangles at least I love triangles it's
the building block of communities it's
you know it's the sign of social
networks it's you know the subgraph to
rule them all one more lotr reference
and you know I just decided I just went
and picked up a bunch of papers in
various different areas which use
triangles for something else so there's
lots there are lots of papers and Social
Sciences like starting from the 70s
where they look at a graph and they look
at the triangles and they say because
the triangles are there something is
going on and in the physical sciences
which is a very loose term but papers in
like physics papers that are doing
analyses of gaming networks and you know
it comes up over and over again and then
of course there's algorithmics there was
a talk on Monday by uh by called row
where he was looking at the triangles in
the graph and then using that to fluster
and Sir David and I have also done some
work
along those lines so it in general it
comes up in many different places and
I'm not even listing the papers that
actually just count triangles because
that would be even more and so just to
give you an example here a bunch of
graphs are from staff from the snap and
from the law database you know n is the
number of vertices m is the number of
edges t is the number of triangles and
you can see that even for a graph with
15 million edges you have 550 million
triangles sort of an order of magnitude
more for the UK and graph the largest
craft that we could public data set we
could find it has 450 billion triangles
so if you accurately wanted to just say
counter estimate the number of triangles
even with clever and numeration
algorithm is probably not what you want
to do and so we're looking for really
efficient scalable algorithms to get the
number of triangles or to get various
estimates or sort of quote-unquote
statistics of triangles and so and you
know so Andrew talked about the
streaming setting which I will focus
upon and I'm going to go over the slide
because the animation took a long time
so so you know this is sort of crucial
for any real time analytics so like
things at the i am at sandia national
labs were you know we maybe maybe you're
just trying to monitor your internal
network you just want to see what's
going on maybe you want to detect if you
know if if there's a no that's fail or
something you know if there's some sort
of communication pattern that looks bad
then you'd like to have an algorithm
that's just watching the stream of data
so you know this computer talks to this
computer this computer talks to this
computer and you only have little space
but you'd still like to get sort of some
summary of what's going on and so the
way the algorithm works is you know it's
got this tiny space which it maintains
its data structures and so then it moves
on to the next edge does some updates
over there and then moves on to the next
edge does some updates so you can think
of sort of you know the string bus
passing by and so I'm not looking at the
situation that Andrew talked about of
sort of event space here I'm looking of
space that is actually it should be
orders of magnitude smaller than the
stream so all is a bank to be even
smaller than an N
and and as Andrew mentioned which I'll
repeat I don't want any assumption on
the graph or the ordering of the edges
so there's no sort of stochastic
assumption on how the graph is being
generated and also I'm going to focus on
a single pass case because for many of
these applications it's really a single
pass I mean if you want to go back to
the data then you have to sort of load
everything back from from somewhere and
so if the algorithm forget something too
bad i mean the algorithm cannot go back
and check hey was I and J actually
connected at some previous step so
friendly stringent conditions and but
actually so you know I show this
animation where this box is moving
slowly but actually it's kind of like
this the stream is going by you have to
update really quickly and so what I'm
going to focus on is actually just
counting the number of triangles so
let's formalize the model so you have a
stream of edges so at the end of this
the algorithm has seen all the edges
it's got this tiny space think of the
graph that is created by accumulating
all the edges and look at the number of
triangles in that I'll call that capital
T and the algorithm should give some
estimate for this number and so that's
the problem and the algorithm will be
randomized so the algorithm is going to
be flipping coins as it passes through
the stream and so the output will be
sort of correct with high probability
over the coin flips not over the input
so for every input the algorithm will
work with problem when I say high
probability I mean Oh point 99 but you
can you can parameterize that that's not
a problem so is the problem definition
clear so there's a lot of history on
this problem so on the on the theory
side I think you know by yourself at all
in 2002 is the first paper that I could
find that that that talks about this
paper andrew has also done some work on
this I mean these papers do a lot more
than just counting triangles but they do
say something about that and it's gone
all the way up to 2030 whether in recent
theoretical advances in understanding
this problem from the practical side
sort of the only paper that I could find
that was doing small space counting and
this paper
actually a bully all at all kind of
falls in between it's that some theory
it also has some practice but basically
and as they observe their algorithms
start breaking down around a million
edges and even at that point you have to
start storing a lot to be able to get
accurate estimates and so I've been
interested in triangle counting for a
while and then it was natural to ask
whether you can do something better and
what I really wanted was something that
was I wanted some theory but I also
wanted the algorithm to work so what ya
like to actually cut it up to see if it
can do something and so before i get
into the result let's just go over some
basic notation the number of vertices is
n the number of edges em as usual what
will be important is the number of
wedges or the paths of length to which
aisle which I'll denote by W so for
example here you've got wedges there b c
and d and e f and g so these are two two
edges in the graph and capital t is the
total number of triangles and you know
the transitivity is the fraction of
closed wedges so a wedge is closed if it
participates in a triangle and is open
otherwise it's so the and the
transitivity sort of a very standard
notion defined in the social sciences
which is you know the fraction of
clothes red isn't no comment so this is
standard notation and i'll refer to the
transitivity is tau i don't know if that
was the best notation but you know it is
Greek pretty so and again the
transitivity is just you know three
times a number of triangles divided by
the number of witches and so so the main
result is you know on the theory side is
so let's let's fix some epsilon some
parameter and we want to get an additive
estimate for the transitivity so so you
have this this fraction huge as the
fraction of closed wedges again this is
sort of a standard notion that is used
for you know sort of social network
analytics beast at some level and so
we'd like to estimate this quantity as
accurately as possible as a fix of
epsilon so what the algorithms features
are is that it's actually going to give
an output that is tell prime such that
tau minus tau prime is at most epsilon
with high probability the space it uses
a square
root n so basically if n is the number
of vertices and it doesn't need to know
n in advance yeah actually if you when
you implement the algorithm you can just
say here's the amount of space that you
can use and we'll go ahead and use that
but by far the most interesting feature
of this algorithm is that it doesn't
work if you if you try to code it it
would just it doesn't do anything useful
and so what I think at least personally
what I think like the real contribution
is actually a sort of heuristic fix for
this problem so we're able to sort of
get to why the space why it doesn't work
it's a somewhat principled fix piece
that's what I think and it works pretty
well in practice so you know okay sorry
you guys for the ad but you know the
best result we could get was actually we
had a graph with 200 million edges and
the storage is basically like 40 40
edges 40,000 edges and it estimates the
transitivity to up 2.01 error so it
actually nails it down pretty well
around the same time there are paper
came out there is an alternative paper
by bhavana at all which uses an
alternative approach which also works
well in practice and maybe at the end if
you if you ask me I can tell you
differences in sort of contrast between
the results but I'll focus on our result
in this town so no it's irregular it's
an addict as an editor it's not a better
so the relative will be progressively
worse as doubt become smaller because so
what's the basic scheme so you will fix
the graph stream in advance right
because we have to work on all graphs or
all orders so just fix some stream and
what we're going to construct is or what
we like to construct is this this thing
that I'll just call the box so the box
is going to make one pass over the
stream and it's just going to output a
Bernoulli random variable so it's going
to flip some coins it's going to do
something and just output 0 or 1 and
what we'd like is that the expectation
of that 0 1 variable is stuff meaning
that the probability that x is equal to
one should exactly be tough so let's say
that we could construct some box for
this using whatever space using whatever
methods well then
natural scheme would be you club a bunch
of these iid boxes together so you run
many independent instantiations of this
box and so you get x 1 x 2 so on and so
forth for each box and so these are all
iid they're all Bernoulli and you could
just output the fraction of these that
are one as your estimate tub friend so
is it so the expectation of this
fraction is exactly tell and so this
would be your estimate so any any
questions on that yeah I'm so yeah it's
a good point so the box actually happens
to be part of both the thing that
doesn't work and the thing that works
but but yeah so right now I'm describing
the theory yeah but the box actually
works so it's about combining these
boxes where the heuristic comes in the
box works in practices with and so you
know you use the Chernoff but not if you
don't use the turn off phone you can't
call yourself for theoretical computer
scientist you have to use it like five
times a day so you can use it and you
know basically it says if if k is
roughly 1 over epsilon squared then
you're guaranteed that Dow minus tau
prime is is absolutely is that most
epsilon so note that there's the squared
so to cut your letter in half you know
you have to eat its quadratic and so the
total amount of space you need is you
know whatever space you need for this
box divided by epsilon squared I mean if
you follow the scheme and if you could
construct this box then this is what you
would get and so far everything is in a
threat a'kla sound so so what's in
what's in the box right so so it's you
know we can we can almost start
illogically define what it needs to be
so now you know the transitivity is the
fraction of closed wedges so suppose you
went ahead and you listed just think as
a thought experiment you listed all
wedges in the graph so you have you know
lkf this is an open wedge you have adb
that's an open wedge as well because
that edge is not present and then this
wedge gjh this is closed because it
participates in a triangle you can list
this entire thing the fraction of sort
of closed entries is exactly the
transitivity so
what you want the box to do is to sample
a uniform at random wedge which I'll
denote by you AR and you just set X is
equal to one if it's closed in X is
equal to zero otherwise so this random
variable is exactly what we're looking
for so thought logically this is what we
want the problem is how do you sample a
uniform at random wedge from an edge
stream because all you're seeing are
edges and you want to sample a wedge and
you're not assuming anything about the
ordering so this is the problem that we
need to deal with and so picking random
edges from the stream is actually easy
so this is reservoir sampling and so if
you just had if you could only store one
edge you could make one pass through
this and end up with the uniform at
random edge so you could copy this as
many times as you want it's easy to pick
up random edges from a stream how many
do you need to pick before you get a way
that's that's you know that would be one
easy way of doing it just pick as many
edges as you need to get a wedge so I
this picture actually shows this much
more better so suppose you're just
randomly picking edges with replacement
from the graph say pick an edge you pick
another you pick another you keep
picking until boom you get a collision
now you have a wedge so if you step back
essentially think of there being n
marbles labeled 1 to N and you are
picking them with replacement the
probability of picking the ayaat marble
is the degree of I right so that's the
probability that you when you pick an
edge you would actually see this vertex
and so it's basically saying you just
repeatedly pick from this distribution
until you see the same thing twice but
this we know what it is this is the
birthday paradox calculation so the
birthday paradox calculation basically
says if you pick randomly if you just
kept picking people how many people you
need to see before two people have the
same birthday well you can do this
calculation for any distribution so you
have some distribution some discrete
distribution you repeatedly sample from
this how long do this before you see the
same thing twice and the calculation
says that basically em over square root
w uniform at random edges suffice so
again m is the number of edges w is the
number of wedges and if this doesn't
make much sense basically this is it
root n under some fairly basic and
fairly acceptable conditions and so that
those are number of edges you need to
get to get a wedge and so is that feel
okay and so now we have the box the box
will basically pick up a bunch of random
edges you know em over root wo root n of
them and that will give it its wedge and
we can now just check yes that the slide
so exactly so now you need to check
whether the wedge is open or closed and
now that seems you might have a problem
so let's say that this wedge was
actually closed but the closing edge the
green blue edge actually appeared first
so by the time you pick this wedge which
is at this point the closing edges
already passed you by which you may not
have stored well there's a there's a
simple fix for this it's it's sort of
subtle but there's a there's a fix for
this which was observed by booya little
which is well look at any triangle there
is one way and exactly one way that is
closed in the future right because a
triangle is three edges so first this
edge came then this edge then this edge
so if you look at this wedge instead
which is you know blue green and blue
green and green red then the closing
edge comes later so when you pick this
where job the closing thing will be in
the future and so if you actually
estimate the fraction of what I'll call
future closed wedges which is exactly
tau divided by three so then you get
your answer when you scale by three so
this is the fix for this issue and so
you put it all together you've got a
bunch of boxes each one keeps track of
its wedge and it just keeps track of
open or closed and okay root and space
for constant error epsilon it's
beautiful and we're done and it doesn't
work so why doesn't it work let's do a
back-of-the-envelope calculation the
space we needed was rootin by epsilon
squared roughly so let's say you're a
graph with a million vertices and you
wanted an additive error of point zero
one which is fairly acceptable
parameters you plug it in and you get
ten to the seven over here so the
epsilon squared just kills this
algorithm and actually that you can do a
little better than root n you can knock
off an order of magnitude there but this
will just the square is too bad so let's
go to heuristic world now
let's just Club all these button you've
got a bunch of different boxes let's
just Club all the edges together and you
know maybe you could get more wedges you
know this edge could collide with this
edge and maybe you get more wedges so
what Chernov says is to get an epsilon
ever you need 1 over epsilon square
wedges so and this you can't improve you
need 1 over epsilon square wedges to get
that accurate estimate now the
interesting thing is if you look into
the birthday paradox a little more
carefully it says if you selected k root
and uniform at random edges then you
will get k square uniform at random
wedges with high probability so when k
is equal to 1 you just get one that's
just birthday paradox but as you
increase this linearly you increase your
space linearly the number of wedges
grows quadratically the problem is that
Chernov needs independent wedges the
birthday paradox gives you dependent
wedges but we'll just assume they're
independent because we're in heuristic
world now and so that's what we'll do
and so suppose the writers were
sufficiently d correlated I don't even
know what that means but I just put it
up there then root n over epsilon edges
should suffice because you would get
enough collisions there you can just
keep those wedges keep track of them
being open and closed and say huge
savings so you knock off a 1 over
epsilon factor which is luck which is a
lot and so this is the algorithm that we
actually implement and so this is like
where i show you results but i'm just
going to say it works but
if any of you have seen that comic
you'll know why there is a black box
over there this is from XKCD by the way
but Maria here is transitivity estimates
for for a laundry list of drafts and you
know the exact isn't blue the estimate
is in red so a total storage we use is
40,000 edges so that's the total pool
and so here's the orchid graph for 200
million edges and you know it nails it
down pretty well so it does really well
on all these instances if you look at
the relative error in triangle counts
then of course it looks worse because
for instances like the web rough when
the transitivity is actually very small
an additive estimate doesn't translate
to a good relative estimate but in the
cases but it's still less than six
percent for sort of all these drops
except for this web graph were actually
the transitivity estimate is tiny and
something that actually I thought was
more interesting with it you can
actually keep track of the clustering
the transitivity and the number of
triangles in real time as the graph is
evolving so we took a patent network of
16 million edges and the storage in this
case was a hundred 100k and it tracks
you can see that the transitivity
actually you know sort of flattened and
it starts shooting up and the same with
the number of triangles the problem with
these plots is actually validating them
is really painful because the algorithm
runs but then you have to actually go
and compute the thing exactly so these
algorithms might give new analytics that
we can use so so I starting to some of
my colleagues and so this is really cool
look at our result it actually works in
practice and the responses breath oh
well you know so real graphs are
actually monkey grabs right you have
edges that repeat I mean if one computer
communicates with another it's going to
do so again in the future and you can't
ignore that and that completely kills
the algorithm and you can't remove
repeated edges from the stream because
you have to make one more pass over the
thing so that was our response but but
we had a follow-up result we have a
follow-up result where we can extend
this to multi graphs and it goes through
fairly seamlessly which is interesting
okay so I don't think that this result
is not mathematically sophisticated but
the reason why I like it is because now
we can go to our practitioner
and say look I mean there are messiness
in the data that we can hope to handle
and sort of making progress towards this
I think is important okay so now we have
this result so who cares thing is nobody
really cares about about triangles
because nobody just wants the
transitivity nobody just wants the
number of triangles this is one single
number which which doesn't capture all
that is going on in the graph and so
this is where I segue into the open
problem section which is what I want
which I wanted to end with is that what
would be very useful is if we could do
things like estimate so T sub B would be
the number of triangles incident to
vertex V if we could estimate this for
all high degree vertices for example or
we could estimate T sub D which is the
number of triangles incidentally degree
D vertices so this is related to
clustering coefficients so these things
are actually useful in the sense that
there are analytics or like for example
we have this application where we want
to model a graph and we really need
these numbers and if we have these
numbers and if we could get them in a
streaming fashion that would be really
useful I suspect one might have to get
some random order assumptions on the
stream but this would be useful sudden
jumps in the clustering coefficient this
would be this would be this would be
very nice and at a more higher level
sort of relating to to Andrew stock I
mean what we discussed the tools were
actually baby stuff for free streaming
algorithms theory what about using sort
of much more heavier tools the kind of
things that the Andrew was talking about
like LP sampling or further loan makai
senki style of hashing and things like
that maybe we could generate sort of a
stronger set of tools with which we
could do more and so the last was so
this is actually this was spurred by a
dr. Jenn gave it at Sandia so so she you
know am at Neverland compeller have this
have this nice paper where they're
talking about how do you get a
representative subsample of a stream
graph so at a much higher level it's not
just for triangle counting or just for
this it's that preserves most of the
structure and so what I started thinking
was ok so our sample only counts
triangles but can you do something else
with it it would be
nice if that same sample could do more
and I think it has some sort of flavor
of induced ed sampling some methods that
the gin is proposed so yeah so I'll end
with that and so thank you